HOST: Jon, Keith,
congratulations.
When you came to this
forge you used our tools
and our equipment
to forge signature
blades in your signature style.
Now, we're sending
you back to your home
forge where you will
recreate an iconic weapon
from history, the xiphos.
The xiphos was a
double-edged short sword
wielded in ancient
Greece by the hoplites
around the 6th century BC.
The hoplites were
armored soldiers
famed for battling
in phalanx formation,
a virtually impenetrable
wall of shields and spears.
If a hoplite's spear was
broken or lost in battle,
his trusty xiphos
served as backup.
Much like Frodo's
iconic sword Sting
in "The Lord of the
Rings", the xiphos
featured a leaf-shaped profile
and short blade length.
Effective for
thrusting and slashing
in close quarters combat.
It lives on in Greek literature
as a classic weapon of warfare,
notably brandished by
Achilles in Homer's
epic poem "The Iliad."
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
[music playing]
KEITH: This will
be the first time
I've ever built a xiphos sword.
Forged in fire in Greek.
I'm going to try to put that
right on the hilt. In the fire
we go.
I love working with
steel because you're
watching your baby being
born right before your eyes.
The sword's coming
along real nice.
The metal is doing exactly
what I wanted to do.
My wife and I are very active
in the pirate reenactment
community.
And that's really where I got
my start in making blades.
And that's why I have the
pirate motif over there.
JON: Today I'm going
to do my annealing.
I'm making a container
to hold my vermiculite
in sand, which will allow me
to anneal my blade overnight.
Vermiculite in sand
is a good mixture
for containing that heat
for long periods of time,
allowing me to quench my blade
tomorrow without any weirdness
occurring.
Here we go.
Getting towards
critical temperature.
[music playing]
[bleep]
Not even close.
Didn't even get like
half of it in there.
My vermiculite and sand
mixture was too dense,
so the blade fought
me on the way down.
And now please don't be bent.
And now I have a bent blade.
My blade may not
be as strong now.
If my annealing medium
isn't going to work tonight,
I definitely don't want to
anneal during my day tomorrow.
Way too much time.
I'll just have to
straighten out, normalize
it, and quench it right now.
The blade is coming
along real well.
The grip and the handle and the
tang is starting to take shape.
Now cutting the
umbilical cord, and we're
going to birth a baby.
There you go.
Now I have to heat treat it.
Fingers crossed and here we go.
I didn't hear any tings.
That's a great sign, I think
we have a real good blade.
Baby just got baptized.
The quench went pretty well.
I think we have a
good blade here.
Excellent.
I am a little bit
behind schedule,
so I decided to
not make the horse
guard that I wanted to do.
But last night it
came to me in a dream.
I have a much
simpler guard design.
It's going to be straight
with some curly cues up.
A little
Celtic-inspired, but much
more simple and traditional.
It's pretty good.
The blades got to be
finished tomorrow,
so that's the game plan.
Finish of the blade.
KEITH: I did a little test
and dropped the blade tip
first right into the cement.
To see how the blade would fare
against something real hard.
Cracks the cement,
nothing on the tip.
Nice work here.
Now, I'm going to
attach the handle,
and then to all the etching.
There is a hidden tang.
The tang is no more.
I feel great.
Real happy with the blade.
I can't wait to chop something.
We're going to sacrifice
a virgin pineapple.
Sweet.
JUDGE 1: Bladesmiths, this
is the sharpness test.
I will take your weapon
and test its edge
by cutting the rope which
will release the sandbags
and then cut the sandbag.
Let's see how sharp
your blades are.
Jon, you're up first.
You ready?
Ready to go.
[music playing]
JUDGE 1: OK Jon.
This side is very sharp.
And the other side is sharp,
but to get through the rope
it took three cuts.
The balance overall of
the sword feels good.
This sir, will cut.
Thanks.
JUDGE 1: Good job.
Keith you're up, you ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
That was cool.
JUDGE 1: All right,
Keith, your blade
required two slices to
cut through the rope,
but it did cut through.
And then on the backhand slice,
cut nicely on the sandbag.
Like the guard, I
like the details
that you put into your blade.
This sir, will cut.
JUDGE 2: Gentlemen, to test
the strength of your weapons
I'm going to take two blows
on either side of this helmet.
See how your weapons hold up.
Jon you're up first.
Are you ready?
I guess so.
JUDGE 2: OK.
[music playing]
Not a mark on the blade.
Very nicely done with that.
One thing I did notice, we just
got a little loose down here.
Right there in your
guard and your pommel.
It's not terrible, but
there's a little movement.
But you've got a very
strong blade here.
Thank you.
JUDGE 2: Nicely done.
So Keith, you're up, you ready?
Aye.
JUDGE 2: All right.
[music playing]
JUDGE 2: It held up well.
I like your handle a lot,
it's contoured to my hand.
All and all really nicely done.
HOST: Bladesmiths.
The judges have made
a final decision.
Jon, Keith, in this final
round of competition
you've both delivered
exactly what we asked for.
But there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Keith, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Jon, unfortunately your
weapon did not make the cut.
Jon, your blade did very
well on the strength test.
The issue we found was
in the fit and finish
of your handle construction.
Your pommel, either it
came loose or it was loose.
And there was some gapping
that we could see through it.
And it's for this reason,
we have to let you go.
Understood.
HOST: Jon, please
surrender your weapon.
I've had a great time, and
I've learned more about myself
and bladesmithing than I have
at any other point in my life.
$10,000 would've been nice,
but I can go earn that $10,000
grand with what I've learned.
I may not be the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
but I definitely won best hair.
Well, Keith, at
least you didn't
get all dressed up for nothing.
You're our new "Forged in
Fire" champion, and will be
receiving a check for $10,000.
Oh my gosh.
I just want to jump up and down
and scream, "yay, I did it!"
"Forged in Fire"
champion, life doesn't
get much better than that.
[music playing]